[Musique]
la france et d'autres pays du globe
doivent faire face à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comment expliquer ce phénomène
depuis tout temps vous avez eu un taux
de chômage important et puis en revanche
des demandes des entreprises pour
engager des gens et qu'ils ne seront
contrés pas parce que formation
insuffisante parce que
inadéquation entre des gens qui étaient
sur le marché du travail est ce que
cherchait les entreprises et à chaque
reprise économique on bute sur des
normes pénurie de main d'oeuvre si on
répond pas tout de suite avec la
concurrence il peut y avoir des
effondrements de certains pans de notre
activité c'est un phénomène sur lequel
il faut travailler sur le temps long
malheureusement le connaissez tous le
temps politique il n'est pas en temps
longs il les entend élections par
élections
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
elle est une alger ne décolère pas après
la décision
réduire ces visas en provenance du
maghreb
rappel de son ambassadeur à paris hier
et interdictions aujourd'hui aux avions
militaires français en partance pour le
sai de survoler son territoire à des
propos d' emmanuel macron dans les
colonnes du monde ont mis le feu aux
poudres les détails à suivre dans cette
édition
[Musique]
ce dimanche à et lundi 12 millions
d'italiens sont appelés à élire leurs
maires d'élection de poids pour les
dunes rome turin milan bologne naples et
trieste un premier scrutin test pour
voir le premier ministre mario draghi et
son gouvernement le second tour est
prévu les 16 et 17 octobre
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également au moins deux
morts et plusieurs blessés dans un
attentat à kaboul aujourd'hui aux abords
d'une mosquée l'explosion d'une bombe
s'est déroulée alors que se tenait les
funérailles d'un proche d'un haut
responsable taliban
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
la crise s'accentue entre alger et paris
avec l'interdiction du survol du
territoire algérien aux avions
militaires français en partance pour le
sahel et hier le gouvernement algérien a
rappelé son ambassadeur à paris pour des
consultations on en parle tout de suite
avec notre correspondant au maghreb
bassam chérie
fm bonsoir alors la crise entre alger et
paris elle est clairement monté d'un
cran aujourd'hui
bonsoir vraiment a effectivement le
pierre menez pas choisi au hasard cette
crise est montée d'un cran entre alger
et paris après la polémique déjà des
visas qu'on a pu voir la semaine
dernière au paris avait annoncé une
réduction de -50 % des visas pour la
france pour les algériens et les
marocains de -30% pour les tunisiens et
évoquant notamment un manque de
coopération des pays d'afrique du nord
concernant la délivrance de documents
consulaire nécessaire à l'expulsion de
personnes en situation régulière ce qui
avait provoqué en algérie au maroc et en
tunisie l'incompréhension et la colère
est là on a un point de plus dans les
tensions entre l'algérie et la france
avec la fermeture aujourd'hui l'espace
aérien aux avions militaires français et
ce au lendemain du rappel de
l'ambassadeur d'algérie à paris ses
avions militaires français ils ont rompu
le droit de survoler l'algérie
contrairement à ce qui était monnaie
courante pour la remet en selle dans le
cadre de l'opération barkan pour
rejoindre le nord du mali depuis ce
matin l'état-major français a pris
connaissance de cette interdiction de
survol de l'espace algérien signe de
l'accentuation d'une crise majeure entre
les deux pays cette décision intervient
dans un contexte assez particulier
samedi donc hier
l'ambassadeur d'algérie a été rappelé
pour consultations selon alger eag alger
qui a exprimé son rejet catégorique à
des déclarations attribuées à emmanuel
macron algique a évoqué notamment une
incompréhension une colère et notamment
une ingérence de la france dans les
affaires algériennes car emmanuel macron
avait déclaré à un système politico
militaire qui est au pouvoir en algérie
est actuellement ces propos qui n'ont
pas été démentie par emmanuel macron
anteros transcrit même par nos confrères
du monde comme vous l'avez dit samantha
dans un article paru
hier le quotidien relate notamment une
rencontre deux jours plus tôt entre le
président de la république et une
vingtaine de jeunes qui sont descendants
de d'acteurs de la guerre d'algérie
selon le même quotidien le monde le chef
de l'état aurait déclaré qu après
l'indépendance de l'algérie en 62
l'algérie s'est construite sur une rente
mémorielle entretenu par un système
politico militaire évoquant également
une histoire officielle totalement
réécrite par alger qui ne s'appuient pas
sur des vérités mais sur un discours qui
repose sur une haine de la france il
n'en fallait pas moins pour mettre le
feu aux poudres et avoir une interaction
assises virulente de l'algérie l'algérie
qui a rappelé son ambassadeur ce qui est
un signe fort quand un pays rappelle son
ambassadeur pour consultations
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui une
valve difficultés diplomatiques entre la
france et l'algérie monte d'un cran et
montre surtout à quel point la question
de la mémoire est très sensible côté
algérien les deux pays a été pourtant
mis d'accord l'année dernière pour
concilier des chercheurs des deux rives
d'amitié un travail de mémoire dans une
optique de réconciliation entre paris et
alger 6 nuls à la tension est vraiment
vide entre la france et l'algérie
détention alors que les deux pays
devraient notamment bientôt commémorer
les 60 ans de la fin de la guerre
d'algérie et son indépendance merci
beaucoup à vous bassam ces billets pour
toutes cette précision
et on va écouter l'analyse de kader
abderrahim il est maître de conférences
à sciences po directeur de recherche à
l'ipp ce auteur du livre géopolitique de
l'algérie aux éditions bibliomonde pour
lui les propos d'emmanuel mâcon que l'on
vient d'évoquer constitue un appel de
pied au mouvement ira qui pourrait du
coup se renforcer l'écouté c'est aussi
un appel et la croix je crois que le
présent macro ont dit en gros je fais ma
part il faut vous preniez vos
responsabilités il s'adresse aux
algériens et je crois que c'est un
message qui va être entendu il ya eu une
longue période pendant laquelle la fin
de bouteflika a été absolument
catastrophique pour l'algérie qui s'est
progressivement enfoncés dans un
isolement dont elle peine aujourd'hui à
sortir parce qu'elle n'a pas de nouveau
projet un point bas droit et environ
2500 partisans du président tunisien
caixa aide se sont rassemblés ce
dimanche à tunis et le soutiennent son
coup de force du 25 juillet dernier lui
donnant lé plein pouvoir au nom de la
lutte anti corruption elle les
manifestants se sont rassemblés cet
après midi sur l'artère principale du
centre de tunis l'avenue bourguiba où
les forces de l'ordre étaient déployées
en nombre à partisans du chef de l'état
ils n'ont pas hésité à brandir le
drapeau national des photos du président
cède et des banderoles assure encore le
peuple veut une révision de la
constitution
écoutez
on veut que kaïs saïd prennent la place
et qu'il demande des comptes aux députés
au parti
sur les dix dernières années où est
passé l'argent et qu'on antil fait que
tous les corrompus prennent leur
responsabilité
c'est une chose incroyable ce qu'a fait
cai sayed une chose extraordinaire
pourquoi pour mettre fin à la corruption
qu'il y a dans le pays tous les
corrompus doivent quitter le pays le
seul qui a accompli son devoir s'écaille
sayyed
[Musique]
je suis venu car il y en a marre nous ne
voulons plus vivre dans ce désordre nous
ne faisons que reculer nous ne sommes
pas en train d'avancer toutes les
affaires sont à l'arrêt économie social
culture tout est à l'arrêt et cela ne
nous convient plus
12 millions à d'italiens appelé
aujourd'hui aux urnes pour élire leurs
maires un scrutin test pour le chef du
gouvernement mario draghi puisqu'il
s'agit à des premières élections
organisées depuis la formation de sa
coalition d'union nationale en février
dernier plus de 1000 villes sont
concernées dont turin milan à naples ou
encore rome une capitale d'ailleurs
accablé par une gestion désastreuse des
ordures le nouveau maire devra s'y
attaquer de front les précisions avec
françois this kevin
un sanglier se balade tranquillement
près d'un quartier résidentiel
une scène loin d'être inhabituel dans la
capitale italienne accablé par une
gestion désastreuse des ordures à chaque
coin de rue les poubelles débordent le
mois dernier le magazine américain time
out classe même rome en tête des villes
les plus sales du monde avec new york et
bangkok au plus grand désespoir des
habitants et des touristes
avant les poubelles des restaurants et
des bars été ramassés de nuit aussi à
une heure du matin ou à deux heures
les poubelles ne restez pas sur les
trottoirs comme maintenant et du coup ça
a tiré - les animaux maintenant la ville
s'est remplie d'animaux d'oiseaux de
corbeaux de mouettes sans parler des
souris et des cafards
ce qui ne va pas c'est que les rues sont
très sale et pas nettoyé et je pense que
c'est un grand handicap pour hommes qui
donnent une mauvaise impression
des déchets enjeux des élections
municipales dans la capitale italienne
des quatre principaux candidats ont
d'ailleurs rivaliser de propositions
pour y remédier comme par exemple un
nettoyage extraordinaire de la ville
après leur élection la mère virginia
rajhi candidate un second mandat défend
son bilan
au cours de ces dernières années nous
avons sauvé une ville du gouffre une
ville qui était complètement abandonné
en effet la mauvaise habitude de
dépenser les fonds publics c'est à dire
l'argent de chaque contribuable la
mauvaise habitude d'attribuer les
services publics et d'acheter des biens
en recourant à des contrats directs et
non à des appels d'offres a créé à rome
un système malsain de mauvaise gestion
de la ville qui a ensuite été découvert
par le procès mafia capital
malades des captiva de gestion de la
crise à cause des
roms préoccupations également pour le
premier ministre mario draghi annonçant
ce mardi la candidature de la ville pour
l'exposition universelle de 2030 outre
la capitale plus d'un millier de
communes sont appelés à renouveler leur
administration comme milan turin et
bologne dans le nord ainsi que naples
dans le sud un scrutin-test pour mario
draghi qui ne s'est pas départi de son
éternel neutralité laissant les partis
composant depuis février dernier sont
hétéroclites majorité s'affronter au
niveau local et ainsi tester leur
popularité alors qu'en février prochain
l'italie devra élire son président et en
mai de l'année suivante ces
parlementaires selon les derniers
sondages le parti conservateur fratelli
d'italia de giorgia meloni et la ligue
nationaliste de matteo salvini rassemble
plus de 40% des intentions de vote au
niveau national
les élections de ces prochains jours
tandis que le parti démocrate devrait
largement l'emporter à milan bologne et
naples mais le comportement des 12
millions d'électeurs reste incertain
quatre italiens sur dix se disent
toujours indécis des élections
municipales qui devraient peser lourd
sur les échéances électorales nationales
à venir écouter l'analyse de fabien
gilles ball est enseignant à
l'université de turin ce qui sera
intéressant pour mario draghi
aujourd'hui c'est de voir quels sont les
partis qui s'en sortent le mieux quelle
est la tendance actuelle car si dans
deux ans il ya de nouveaux livres à dont
l'élection est peut-être que justement
mario draghi restera aux affaires car
certains le souhaitent on va dire c'est
un peu un sentiment général dans tous
les cas mais si mario draghi rester
après l'élection dans deux ans il faudra
tous les cas recomposée qu'un nouveau
format ça c'est sûr deux partis
politiques pour avoir une majorité et
donc pour mario draghi c'est très
important de regarder ce type d'élection
pour savoir avec qui il devra travailler
demain
car les ce que je demande est arrivé en
sardaigne aujourd'hui où un juge doit
décider de son extradition en espagne en
catalogne en tout cas on s'est mobilisé
pour célébrer le référendum non
autorisée d'autodétermination d'octobre
2010 est elle les indépendantistes
toujours aussi déterminés à obtenir gain
de cause les détails avec clémentine le
rend à barcelone
trois jours de manifestation cette année
les indépendantistes catalans commémore
l'anniversaire du référendum
d'autodétermination en grande pompe
c'est ce référendum qui en 2017 avait
mené le gouvernement catalan de l'époque
a déclaré l'indépendance de la région
la mobilisation a commencé ce vendredi
1er octobre avec un image spéciale aux
militants qui ont rendu possible le
scrutin en cachant les urnes
e les marchands donc été organisée entre
la france et l'espagne ce vendredi à
barcelone le 1er octobre a aussi a donné
lieu à des heurts avec la police une
centaine de personnes ont manifesté des
poubelles ont été incendiées et quatre
personnes ont été arrêtées samedi 2
octobre des marches populaires ont été
organisés dans toute la catalogne et
puis ce dimanche 3 octobre dernier jour
de la mobilisation
une grande manifestation est organisée
sur la plus grande artère de barcelone
il faut rappeler que le 3 octobre comme
un an également la grande grève générale
qui avait eu lieu après le référendum en
2017 pour les manifestants les
revendications n'ont pas changé depuis
quatre ans je vous propose de les
écouter
la volonté d'indépendance est la même
qu'avant je dirais qu'elle s'est
renforcée car durant ces quatre
dernières années on a vu la réponse
répressive de l'espagne et si quelqu'un
avait encore un doute maintenant il est
convaincu
nous venons d'un petit village près de
barcelone et nous sommes venus en
famille car c'est pour leur avenir nous
voulons défendre leur avenir et nous ne
pouvons pas admettre que l'on piétine
nos droits
la star y va l'espoir est plus vivant
que jamais surtout quand arrive
l'automne on se souvient les jours
d'octobre 2010 est évidemment l'espoir
est plus que jamais vivant
depuis cet été une table de négociation
est en cours entre madrid et barcelone
pour trouver une issue au problème
catalan mais elle n'a pas donné de
résultat concret pour le moment
le commis de long vous en avez
certainement entendu parler il s'agit de
la persistance de symptômes chez un
patient atteint des mois plus tôt par le
coronavirus un malheur reconnu par la
majorité des chercheurs et par plusieurs
autorités sanitaires alors pourquoi
certains patients en sont atteints et
pas d'autres comment les traiter pour
l'instant aucune réponse claire on voit
cela avec et estelle fâche
il reste un mystère pour de nombreux
médecins du monde entier mais il a un
nom le qu'ovide long pour de nombreux
malades le coc u19 a été la sphère de
quelques jours mais pour d'autres les
symptômes durent depuis plusieurs mois
voici comment la haute autorité de santé
présentent en france ce qu'est le
coville long la haute autorité de santé
utilise le terme de symptômes prolongé
suite à la copie de 10,9 il s'agit de
symptômes qui persiste au delà de quatre
semaines après la date présumée de
contamination et qui ne sont pas dus à
une autre maladie le plus souvent il y a
plusieurs symptômes ils peuvent être
différentes d'une personne à l'autre et
d'intensités différentes l'existence de
covile ont fait l'objet d'un consensus
dans le monde médical en revanche les
causes de la persistance des symptômes
et leurs conséquences restent
aujourd'hui un grand flou pour tenter
d'en savoir plus l'université d'oxford a
mené une étude sur le sujet les dossiers
de plus de deux cent soixante treize
mille survivants ducobu 19 habitants
principalement aux états unis qui ont
été examinés
cette étude a utilisé les données des
dossiers de santé électroniques de 273
1618 patients diagnostiqués qu'ovide 19
et a estimé le risque d'avoir des
caractéristiques kovy 19 dans les six
mois suivant un diagnostic de kovy de 19
l'étude a comparé le risque de
caractéristiques de longue durée de kobe
dans différents groupes de la population
et a également comparé ce même risque
après une grippe selon les résultats de
cette étude les symptômes prolongée de
la maladie sont plus fréquents chez les
anciens malades ducobu de 19 que chez
ceux de la grippe pendant les six mois
qui suivent leur contamination au
qu'ovide 19 ils sont 57% à présenter
encore un ou plusieurs symptômes du
colis de 19
l'étude a révélé que plus dans patient
sur trois présenter une ou plusieurs
caractéristiques de covile l'on
enregistré entre trois et six mois après
un diagnostic de 19 ce taux était
significativement plus élevé qu'après la
grippe le coc vie 19 semble être associé
à des effets à long terme qui sont
communs et divers avec 57 % des patients
ayant au moins une caractéristique du
coc vide l'on enregistré dans les 180
jours après l'infection et 37% les
ayants dans les 90 à 180 jours après le
diagnostic dont 40 % n'en avais pas eu
dans les trois premiers mois les
chercheurs restent cependant prudents
selon eux l'étude laissent penser que
l'origine de ces symptômes persistants
pourrait être en partie liée à une
infection au virus du coc vide toujours
est il que certains malades ont vu leur
vie bouleversée en raison de ce qu vie
blond en belgique par exemple une
association de malades demandent une
reconnaissance officielle du coville
long comme maladie professionnelle
en france le passage et tara et de
vigueur et les très contestées chaque
samedi c'était la 12e journée
manifestation anti passe impasse
sanitaire peut être bientôt instaurer en
côte d'ivoire pour accéder à notamment
au bar et au restaurant en fonction de
l'évolution de l'épidémie de coin qui
étaient là bas les restaurateurs comme
l'a constaté dans la capitale économique
abidjan notre reporter et la femme
nous sommes dans le quartier blockhaus
et un quartier très populaire dans le
nord d'abidjan ou fonctionnaires
ouvriers et étudiants ont l'habitude de
se retrouver autour d'un plat dans les
maquis une véritable institution ici en
côte d'ivoire mais bientôt tout ce monde
pourrait se voir contraint de présenter
un test pcr de moins de 72 heures ou un
certificat de vaccination pour pouvoir
se retrouver entre amis quoi ont conclu
à quoi quand on est obligés de faire le
vaccin sinon c'est la cata quoi mon
personnage est moins choquant
viendra que les sels et bien expliqué et
puis j'aime leur pape lui impose et
chacun est libre de fait son choix mais
si la liberté du lieu d'inquiéter sur la
liberté de tous arrivé sur mon faut que
l'état impose la
ve les patientes et c'est un peu bizarre
besoin dit qu'on coupait tout si
l'occident en fait c'est aussi bien pour
nous parce que ça nous protège ça nous
responsabilise donc je sais point fr si
les avis sur ce pass and i ter sont
mitigés codé clientèle du côté des
restaurateurs la perspective de cette
mesure inquiète une profession déjà
fortement impacté par la crise sanitaire
c'est le cas de jean jacques biaggi
patron de l'espace port royal il craint
de voir la fréquentation chuter
drastiquement ses eaux le gouvernement
nous a
envoyé des améliorations pour truc que
gérer on peut gérer avec
ses je suis belge n est ce pas de 500 à
700 personnes on me dit bon des fois que
tu réduisent à peut-être à 301 300
personnes je peux respecter mais son
mehdi de réduit à 100 personnes ce que
je vais faire mais bon si c'est dans
l'objectif or un de
préserver de la maladie on obligé de
faire on va demander pas s'arrêter à
chaque personne et s'il faut même ça
sera comme un passeport avant d'entrer
dans l'espace depuis le 20 septembre
sous les voyageurs en provenance ou à
destination de la côte d'ivoire doivent
être munis d'un pass avec qr code dans
ce centre de formation de l'institut
national de santé publique dans la
commune du plateau une quarantaine
d'agents sont formés quotidiennement
pour renseigner la population sur le
pass and i ter et rassurer ceux qui
restent méfiants vis-à-vis des vaccins
anti corrida qu'aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
venir bout de cette pandémie c'est la
vaccination dont c'est surtout emmenés
la population à se faire vacciner et
surtout faciliter l'accès aux sites de
vaccination aux populations à la longue
en fonction de l'évolution de la
pandémie chez nous on verra s'il faut
casser les mesures pour imposer un pass
and it et ou pas pour entrer dans les
lieux recevant du public dans ce pays de
plus de 27 millions d'habitants seuls 6
% de la population a reçu au moins une
dose de vaccin à ce jour le gouvernement
ivoirien qui a commandé plus de 12
millions de doses mais qui en a reçu que
2 5 millions ce qui rend l'objectif de
vacciner au moins un million de
personnes par mois difficiles à
atteindre
en israël nouveau pas sanitaire est
entrée en vigueur ce dimanche est la
mesure concerne ceux qui ont reçu leur
troisième dose ils sont plus de 3000 4
millions les autres déjà vacciner deux
fois ils sont raides 1,9 million et
vient l'heure pas ce ne sera plus valide
en guise de protestation certains se
sont rassemblés sur une autoroute
aujourd'hui on va écouter l'analyse de
gérard vespière à une les fondateurs du
web magazine le monde décrypté
où nous avons maintenant une grande et
large période d'observation a donc les
scientifiques voient très bien comment
les choses se déroulent nous avons en
israël une situation avec le nouveau
variant
premièrement qui est beaucoup plus
agressive que la forme initiale
deuxièmement la durée de protection des
vaccins classiques et moins grande
vis-à-vis de ce nouveau variant et
troisièmement cette résistance a donné
par les vaccins est différente d'un
fournisseur de vaccins à l'autre donc il
ya vraiment une nécessité
je dirais rationnel scientifique de se
protéger est d'augmenter effectivement
le taux de protection individuelle par
cette troisième dose c'est une mesure
stratégique et il faut accepter que les
stratégies bouge parce que le virus lui
bouge aussi beaucoup n'est ce pas
dans l'actualité cet attentat meurtrier
aujourd'hui dans la capitale afghane au
moins deux civils ont été tués et trois
blessés dans une explosion survenue près
de la mosquée ils garent à kaboul à une
prière à la mémoire de la mère d'une
figure des talibans se dérouler au même
moment dans cette mosquée à la deuxième
la plus importante de la ville sur place
les précisions 1-2 mourad gaz dief
envoyé spécial pour rt internationale
et bien kevin nous avons entendu
l'explosion elle était un peu étouffée
et il était évident que ça venait de
loin le secteur nord de la ville nous
avons essayé de collecter des
informations de découvrir ce qui s'était
passé et les talibans en maintenant
confirmé qu'il y avait eu un certain
nombre de victimes ils n'ont pas précisé
combien de personnes ont été tuées ou
blessées les mêmes à distance nous avons
entendu il est évident qu'il s'agissait
d'une explosion puissante c'était
presque un tremblement de terre mais en
outre nous avons également entendu dire
que l'explosion avait eu lieu près de la
mosquée id gars c'est la deuxième plus
grande mosquée à kaboul et cela a été
confirmé par les talibans
ce que nous avons également entendu par
contre cela n'est pas confirmé c'est
qu'au moment de l'explosion des
funérailles étaient en cours à la
mosquée les funérailles de la mère du
porte parole des talibans zabihullah
moujahed mais cela n'est pas confirmé
pour l'instant nous continuons à avoir
des détails mais nous entendons parler
d'autres victimes civiles là bas et il
s'agit de la plus récente des attaques
de ce genre à kaboul sans parler du
reste de l'afghanistan
il y a des pompiers dans la capitale et
les talibans font face à ce qu'ils
appellent divers éléments terroristes
ainsi qu'à des ch il y a une forte
présence de dèche à kaboul en
afghanistan et les talibans sont du plus
longtemps en guerre contre eux
maintenant alors que les talibans
essayer de consolider leur pouvoir
contrôler les rênes autour de la ville
il y a encore des affrontements entre
les combattants talibans et les
combattants de dèche à travers le pays
de même ce week end il y à une attaque
contre un bureau des taliban à jalalabad
au cours de laquelle quatre personnes
ont été tuées nous avons entendu que
c'était le résultat d'une fusillade et
les habitants en blâme dèche dans
d'autres régions du pays les attaques
contre des convois et des combattants
talibans ont également été perpétrés par
l'état islamique ils en ont revendiqué
certains et d'autres leur ont été
attribués cependant comme je les dis les
etats-unis et leurs alliés se sont
retirés mais cela n'a pas mis fin aux
hostilités en afghanistan ici ces
hostilités continuent les talibans
affrontent ont non seulement des ch mais
aussi d'autres groupes terroristes
islamistes en afghanistan
oc dans l'accord de paix de joux banon
un accord de paix historique entre le
gouvernement soudanais et une alliance
de groupes rebelles qui a mis fin à 17
ans de guerre meurtrière l accord
prévoyait l'inclusion à des populations
marginalisées un partage des richesses
un an plus tard la mise en application
de cet accord est toujours en cours un
accord qui se heurte à de nombreux
obstacles mais l'onu estime qu'il ya du
progrès en matière de gouvernance
démocratique et d'efforts pour la paix
sien
et on va écouter l'analyse de marc
lavergne directeur de recherche cnrs à
et spécialiste du soudan de la corne de
l'afrique
l'idée centrale de cet accord c'est que
le soudeur deviennent d'état fédérale et
sa demande des réformes
constitutionnelles qui n'ont pas eu lieu
jusqu'à présent et puis il ya aussi la
légitimité de cet accord qui est mise en
cause par certains des signataires comme
par d'autres groupes dans la mesure où
le soudan est en phase de transition
démocratique avec un gouvernement civil
mais aussi un conseil de souveraineté où
se trouvent des militaires et puis des
forces
armés des forces de sécurité qui
participent de manière un petit peu
attentiste à cette marche des événements
et un gouvernement qui lui aussi assez
divisés donc il n'y a pas de légitimité
démocratique si vous voulez à cet accord
jusqu'à présent et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
va se retrouver en direct dans une
trentaine à 2 minutes rester avec nous
sur arte france
[Musique]
la communication des modèles mâcon aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien de plus c'est pour se rapprocher
des jeunes mais parce qu'ils sont
beaucoup trop déconnecté de la sphère
politique il pense que ça va ramener les
jeunes à la politique dont il se
désintéresserait en lieu et place de
politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique en la rendant encore plus
clownesque justement c'est une nouvelle
forme de communication assez verticale
utiliser des influenceurs pour un sac
hommes politiques personnelles est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est vraiment
nouveau d'utiliser des célébrités pour
faire de la propagande politique on s'en
fiche nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige
la france comme c'est son travail en
notre nom pour nous aider dans notre
intérêt à tous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
pour
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions coupe du
symbolisme en terme de timing ce sera
absolument parfait et ils veulent une
fanfare un peu aussi pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power i si vous
regardez en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait c'est peanuts donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons de manière plutôt mélioratif
plutôt calme
[Musique]
la france et d'autres pays du globe
doivent faire face à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comment expliquer ce phénomène
depuis tout temps vous avez eu un taux
de chômage important et puis en revanche
des demandes des entreprises pour
engager des gens et qui ne se
rencontraient pas parce que formation
insuffisante parce que
inadéquation entre les gens qui étaient
sur le marché du travail est ce que
cherchait les entreprises et à chaque
reprise économique on bute sur des
normes pénurie de main d'oeuvre si on
répond pas tout de suite avec la
concurrence il peut y avoir des
effondrements de certains pans de notre
activité c'est un phénomène sur lequel
il faut travailler sur le temps long
malheureusement le connaissez tous le
temps politique il n'est pas en temps
longs il est en temps élections par
élections
[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
de la grande interview installés de
façon exceptionnelle dans ce centre
culturel orthodoxe russe à l'ombre de
l'église orthodoxe que tous les
parisiens maintenant connaissent dans ce
quartier de l'alma à paris sur la rive
gauche
émission un peu particulière puisque
nous recevons nous sommes reçus par la
ministre de la culture de la fédération
de russie olga l'oubli mauvais merci à
tous et est active accordé cet entretien
vous êtes à paris à l'occasion de
l'inauguration de l'exposition de la
collection
des frères morozov à la fondation
vuitton
inauguration qui a eu lieu en présence
d' emmanuel macron le président de la
république qui a saisi l'occasion
d'ailleurs de dire que cet événement
marquait la proximité forte entre la
france et la russie cette collection
madame la ministre est absolument unique
au monde et nous permet de découvrir des
trésors de la peinture du 19e siècle et
du début du 20e siècle peintures
européennes françaises russes aussi des
pièces de maxis de sead de renoir des
tableaux qu'on avait jamais vu nulle
part peut-être un peu à moscou et
peut-être à saint pétersbourg pouvez
vous nous raconter
l'histoire de cette collection d'où elle
vient cette collection
les frères morozov sont deux
collectionneurs unique qui ont vécu au
tournant des 19e et 20e siècles
ils sont décédés tous deux peu de temps
avant la révolution
de collectionneurs au flair et au goût
fantastic
grâce à eux nous avons un héritage
extraordinaire
environ 400 toiles d'artistes russes et
deux cent cinquante toiles d'artistes
d'europe occidentale
non non
zapatero madame la ministre tous ces
tableaux aux rues de vie très chahuté
depuis la mort des frères
morozov comment s'est déroulée cette
histoire et comment est-ce que la russie
d'aujourd'hui a ressorti ses tableaux
dans l'actualité pour les présenter
en effet la collection morozov a élu son
domicile au musée de l'ermitage au musée
des beaux-arts pouchkine et à la galerie
tretiakov de moscou
il existe en russie une association de
musée on courait vite très
harmonieusement entre nous c'est donc
une pratique courante surtout pour de si
grands projets
on appelle ça des expositions de grande
envergure quand les trois des plus
grands